[Music]
I am a cultural omnivore one whose daily
commute is made possible by attachment
to an iPod an iPod that contains vogner
and Mozart pop diva Christina Aguilera
country singer Josh Turner got gangster
rap artist Kirk Franklin can share these
symphonies and more and more I'm a
voracious reader a reader who do deals
with Ian McEwan down to Stephenie Meyer
I have read the Twilight tetralogy and
one who lives for my home theater a home
theater write of our DVDs video on
demand and for a lot of television for
me Law & Order SVU Tina Fey in 30 rock
and Judge Judy the people are real the
cases are real the rulings are final now
I'm convinced a lot of you probably
share my passions especially my passion
for Judge Judy and you'd fight anybody
who attempted to take her away from us
but I'm a little less convinced that you
share the central passion of my life a
passion for the live professional
performing arts performing arts that
represent the orchestral repertoire yes
but jazz as well modern dance opera
theater and more and more and more you
know frankly it's a sector that many of
us who work in the field worry is being
endangered and possibly dismantled by
technology while we initially heralded
the Internet as the fantastic new
marketing device that was going to solve
all our problems we now realize that the
Internet is if anything too effective in
that regard depending on who you read an
arts organization or an artist who tries
to attract the attention of a potential
single ticket buyer now competes with
between three and five thousand
different marketing messages a typical
citizen sees every single day we now
know in fact that technology is our
biggest competitor for leisure time five
years ago Gen Xers spent 20.7 hours
online and TV the majority on TV Gen Y
are spent even more twenty three point
eight hours the majority online and now
a typical in typical university entering
student arrives at college already
having spent twenty thousand hours
online and an additional ten thousand
hours playing video games
a stark reminder that we operate in a
cultural context where video games now
outsell music and movie recordings
combined moreover we're afraid that
technology has altered our very
assumptions of cultural consumption
thanks to the internet we believe we can
get anything we want whenever we want it
delivered to our own doorstep we can
shop at 3:00 in the morning or 8:00 at
night ordering jeans tailor-made for our
unique body types ex expectations of
personalization and customization that
the live performing arts which have set
curtain times set venues attended
inconveniences of travel parking and the
like
simply cannot meet and we're all acutely
aware what's it gonna mean in the future
when we ask someone to pay $100 for a
symphony opera or ballet ticket when
that cultural consumer is used to
downloading on the Internet 24 hours a
day for 99 cents a song or for free
these are enormous questions for those
of us that work in this terrain but as
particular as they feel to us we know
we're not alone all of us are engaged in
a seismic fundamental realignment of
culture and communications a realignment
that is shaking and decimating the
newspaper industry the magazine industry
the book and publishing industry and
more saddled in the Performing Arts as
we are by antiquated union agreements
that inhibit and often prohibit
mechanical reproduction in streaming
locked into large facilities that were
designed to ossify the ideal
relationship between artist and audience
most appropriate to the 19th century and
locked into a business model dependent
on high ticket revenues where we charge
exorbitant prices many of us shudder in
the wake of the collapse of Tower
Records and ask ourselves are we next
everyone I talked to in performing arts
resonates to the world of aid words of
Adrienne Rich who in dreams of a common
language wrote we are out in a country
that has no language no laws whatever we
do together is pure invention the maps
they gave us are out of date by years
and for those of you who love the arts
aren't you glad you invited me here to
brighten your day
now rather than saying that we're a bit
brink of our own annihilation I prefer
to believe that we are engaged in a
fundamental Reformation a Reformation
like the religious Reformation of the
16th century the arts Reformation like
the religious Reformation is spurred in
part by technology with indeed the
printing press really leading the charge
on the religious and Reformation both
Reformation czar predicated on fractious
discussion internal self-doubt and
massive realignment of antiquated
business models and at heart both
Reformation I think we're asking the
questions who's entitled to practice how
are they entitled to practice and indeed
do we need anyone to inter mediate for
us in order to have an experience with a
spiritual divine Chris Anderson someone
I trust you all know editor-in-chief of
Wired magazine and author of the long
tale really was the first for me to nail
a lot of this he wrote a long time ago
you know thanks to the invention of the
internet web cell a web technology
minicams and more the means of artistic
production have been democratized for
the first time in all of human history
in the 1930s if any of you wanted to
make a movie you had to work for Warner
Brothers or RKO because who could afford
a movie set and lighting equipment and
editing equipment and scoring and more
and now who in this room doesn't know a
14-year old hard at work on her second
third or fourth movie similarly the
means of artistic distribution have been
democratized for the first time in human
history again in the 30s Warner Brothers
RKO did that for you now go to youtube
facebook you have worldwide distribution
without leaving the privacy of your own
bedroom this double impact is
occasioning a massive redefinition of
the cultural market a time when anyone
is a potential author frankly what we're
seeing now in this environment is a
massive time when the entire world is
changing as we move from a time when
audience numbers are plummeting but the
number of arts
anticipates people who write poetry who
sing songs who perform in church choirs
is exploding beyond our wildest
imaginations this group others have
called the pro am's amateur artists
doing work at a professional level you
see them on YouTube and dance
competitions film festivals and more
they are radically expanding our notions
of the potential of an aesthetic
vocabulary while they are challenging
and undermining the cultural autonomy of
our traditional institutions ultimately
we now live in a world defined not by
consumption but by participation but I
want to be clear just as the religious
Reformation did not spell the end to the
formal church or to the priesthood I
believe that our artistic institutions
will continue to have importance they
currently are the best opportunities for
artists to have lives of economic
dignity not opulence of dignity and they
are the places where artists who deserve
and want to work at a certain scale of
resources will find a home but to view
them as synonymous with the entirety of
the arts community is by far too
short-sighted and indeed while we've
tended to polarize the amateur from the
professional the single most exciting
development in the last five to ten
years has been the rise of the
professional hybrid artist the
professional artist who works not
primarily in the concert hall or on the
stage but most frequently around women's
rights or human rights around global
warming issues or AIDS relief or more
not out of economic necessity but out of
a deep organic conviction that the work
that she or he is called to do cannot be
accomplished in the traditional hermetic
arts environment today's dance world is
not defined solely by the Royal Winnipeg
Ballet or the National Ballet of Canada
but by Liz Lerman's dance exchange a
multi-generational professional dance
company whose dancers range in age from
18 to 82 and who work with genomic
scientists to embody the DNA strand and
with nuclear physicists at CERN today's
professional theater community is
defined not only by the Shah and
Stratford festivals but by the
cornerstone theatre of Los Angeles a
collective of artists after nine
eleven brought together ten different
religious communities the Baha'i the
Catholic the Muslim the Jewish even the
Native American and the gay and lesbian
communities of faith helping them create
their own individual plays and one
massive play where they explored the
differences in their faith and found
commonality as an important first step
toward cross community healing today's
performers like Rajesh Jones work in
women's prisons helping women prisoners
articulate the pain of incarceration
while today's playwrights and directors
work with youth gangs do you find
alternate channels to violence and more
and more and more and indeed I think
rather than being annihilated the
Performing Arts are poised on the brink
of a time when we will be more important
than we have ever been you know we've
said for a long time we are critical to
the health of the economic communities
in your town and absolutely I hope you
know that every dollar spent on a
performing arts ticket in a community
generates five to seven additional
dollars for the local economy dollars
spent in restaurants from parking at the
fabric stores where you buy fabric for
costumes the piano tuner who Tunes the
instruments and more but the arts are
going to be more important to economies
as we go forward especially in
industries we can't even imagine yet
just as they have been central to the
iPod in the computer game industries
which few if any of us could have
foreseen 10 to 15 years ago business
leadership will depend more and more on
emotional intelligence the ability to
listen deeply to have empathy to
articulate change to motivate others the
very capacities that the arts cultivate
with every encounter especially now as
we all must confront the fallacy of a
market only orientation uninformed by
social conscience we must seize and
celebrate the power of the arts to shape
our individual and national characters
and especially characters of the young
people who all too often are subjected
to bombardment of sensation rather than
digested experience ultimately
especially now in this world where we
live in a context of regressive and
onerous immigration laws
reality-tv that thrives on humiliation
and in its context of announcements
where the thing we hear most repeatedly
day-in day-out in the United States in
every train station every bus station
every plane station is ladies and
gentlemen please report any suspicious
behavior or suspicious individuals to
the authorities nearest you when all of
these ways we are encouraged to view our
fellow human being with hostility and
fear and contempt and suspicion the arts
whatever they do whenever they call us
together invite us to look at our fellow
human being with generosity and
curiosity god knows if we have ever
needed that capacity in human history we
need it now you know we're bound
together not I think by Technology
Entertainment Design but by common cause
we work to promote healthy vibrant
societies to ameliorate human suffering
to promote a more thoughtful subjective
empathic World Order I salute all of you
as activists in that quest and urge you
to embrace and hold dear the arts in
your work whatever your purpose may be I
promise you the hand of the Doris Duke
Charitable Foundation is stretched out
in friendship for now and years to come
and I thank you for your kindness and
your patience and listening to me this
afternoon thank you and Godspeed
somewhere in America there's a doctor
who can peer into the future there's a
nurse who can access in an instant every
patients past and because the whole
hospitals working together there's a
family who can breathe easy right now
somewhere in America we've already
answered some of the nation's toughest
health care questions and the over
60,000 people of Siemens are ready to do
it again Siemens answers